Okay so, here's my implementation of the function. First what
we do is we take we, we take this value H,
which has this format and we split it on commas.
And we take the first part of that we store that
in val. And we say if H equals make_secure_val of
val, return val. Val is, is what, is, is the, the,
the s part of what we passed in, and we want
to make sure that if we run this function on that
value again, that we get, what we passed in to this
function. I could've structured this differently. And looked at all of the
parts of h, and then called hash_str again. But if we
funnel everything through make_secure_val, updates to
this function will be easier going
forward. So, because I, I have the advantage of knowing if,
what going forward is going to look like. So let's give this
a test. The first thing we're going to do is we're going to call
make_secure_val on, on some string. So we'll go ahead and give that
a run. Okay, we've got the string and now I'm
going to copy this, and we're going to replace this with check_secure_val.
And we're going to pass in that string, and now we should
see the output Udacity. And let's see if that's the case.
Yes, we do. Udacity, that works. Now what happens if we if we modify this
a little bit, you know, we add an extra exclamation mark? And, and I click Run.
We get nothing back because Udacity didn't match
the hash string. Likewise, if we restore our string
and we change the hash, I'll just get rid
of this character, then run it, we still have
none. And I'll add that, that 2 back and
run it again just to make sure everything's working,
and we see Udacity. Okay, cool nice work. Let's
go ahead and use these functions on our program.